okay we're live
streaming for
full okay so
uh welcome to the extraordinary council
meeting today um and I'll come to a
little bit of housekeeping shortly um so
I just need to run through some some
Basics any
apologies nobody no all
here Peter's here as well nobody zooming
and no public forum now in relation to
the agenda that we have in front of us
um I've advised you all today that we
want to I want to remove recommendations
3 through 8 two reasons for that the
primary the secondary reason is that uh
we'd like us just to have a fresh
discussion about what in the place and
not have the confusion of Ico finances
but more importantly uh last night
myself Tom and Grant met with Michael
Day chief executive about some of the
information that's contained in the
finance report from ICL which we're not
clear about so we've asked Andrew today
and uh that we want a further written
report on that around and particularly
around the $40 million float which
wasn't our recommendation as a
stakeholder in I through hulco and nor
was it what uh the public uh recommended
for us as well so that sits on the table
hopefully we'll have another meeting
within a week or so which will probably
Dov to with another meeting um and we'll
we'll get to that issue when we have a
bit more
information in relation to the
um Suite of options that we've got
around walking the
place I'm about shortly and I've I've
written to you all and advise you
earlier in the day to move an amendment
on option one before I do that just for
the Public's uh perspective as well we
will also to consider the pillars or the
columns as well uh we've had some very
late advice in the last couple of days
to tell us that the pillars potentially
are under the earthquake prone level of
34% um so that makes a significant
difference in our decision- making and
so um Russell has advised that
um the under 34 NBS rating or the device
that we've been given to date um is
subject to analyzing what the base of
the pillars are sitting on so we're
getting some work done on that so um my
recommendation is we don't discuss that
today uh that we go forward and wait for
that final advice there are two issues
with the NBS rating um you you'll all
know that we've had this debate before
um uh a National Building standard code
of under 34 requires remedial action but
it doesn't require remedial action today
so that basically means that we would
have because it's sitting on an arterial
Road 12 1/2 years to strengthen or
remove those pillars so we had that
question in a workshop yesterday I think
Trish mentioned about that one of the
downsides of that is we also have some I
guess some moral or ethical issues as
well so how would it be if we left the
pillars here at the stage knowing they
were under the 34 limit having quite
heavy traffic through at the bottom end
of s Street including people from a new
hotel and we have an
earthquake um and while you can
technically say well we had 12 years to
fix it it doesn't sit well morally if
people are hurt by uh pillars that
collapse so again I'm seeking some
advice from Russell and his engineering
team hopefully that will be back in time
for their next meeting on the 28th of
November he's smiling and nodding so
we'll be able to address the pillars at
that stage so um we just basically left
with uh the walk in place options 1 2
and three which is sitting in the agenda
and I will move uh an amendment to
option one and I've already written
about this um so option one has a clause
within it can you bring it
up
make so the option one has has a
statement that when you get
to
no all yeah there it is in in 11 option
one
right oh sorry after the word buses
which is in the first sentence of option
one I'm recommending that we include the
wording that says while retaining the
clock structure and using the space to
the north and south of the structure for
vehical and pedestrian
movement now the rationale for putting
this up is I've listened carefully to to
what was said at public submissions and
also carefully listen to
um uh what we've been saying around the
table in our workshops and it seems to
me that there is some potential Middle
Ground between us going to option one
and option two option one is that we
have traffic going through walking Place
option two is leave it alone and retain
it for whatever purposes need to be and
I think there can be a win-win by uh
introducing a middle
ground
um so if somebody else would like to
move second Tom thank you uh before I
put the vote anybody like to have some
discussion about
that
so when you say for vehicle access
that's expanding it from BS is that what
you're intending well I'm not at this
day but I I don't want to preclude what
the design features might come back like
in most places where you have yeah i'
got the hands when you have what they
call shared space and queenstown's a
good example of that it's open but the
only things that tend to go through it
are taxis because nobody else wants to
go through it because it's just too slow
I mean the speed might be 5 K an hour or
10ks an hour so there's no benefit um
because it's up for others to decide so
if we change it from bus only X been um
the Ballard with um some form of
mechanism that controlled who could
access it you're now saying any
vehicle provided that they're turning in
the right direction would be able to go
through that that's what a shared
spaces I don't believe that we consulted
on that basis well again I've taken
advice on the um amendments that I'm
looking looking to and the general
consensus I got back from talking to
staff and and the counselors as well was
that we we scoped with the public quite
a range of issues what I'm proposing is
sort of halfway between one and two um
you haven't actually changed the word
buses at the moment unless you intend it
it still says
buses but I did use the word vehicle the
vehicle did you intend to use it was it
well I I just left it open I mean um
because I I I don't see the future use
being Ballard to jump up and jump down
but
so for clarity y you intend the use of
the word vehicle to mean other vehicles
than buses well I I think if you're
going forward you'd think about can
taxis use them to go to and
from are you it um for clarity sake you
wor it for it to be much like how es
street is used at the moment well our
street doesn't actually have any
parkings like we're not suggesting that
you could park and walk in a place but
you could travel through the space if
you look at Queenstown again very little
parking space on those arterial roads
that run around the mall but they do
have shared access which is a guess
Middle Ground between uh spaces being
vehicle concentrated and the alternative
is pedestrian concentrated and there's
always winners and losers on that and it
seems to be that most of the development
going on around the country is a shared
space with a speed reduction which
encourages people not to go in if you
look at the queenstone modwood shop
looked at and sat there and watched it
people don't go through the Shar space
because it's just so slow it's just not
worth doing LLY thanks um Mr M
so the use of the word vehicle is going
to add confusion for the public into
what we are passing the automatic
assumption for our rate payers and
residents will be that that word
includes all vehicle access including
private Vehicles delivery
vehicles the fact that tour buses is
left is not actually going to deal with
that because the word vehicle has
widened
it I think that that either it needs
changed so that vehicle is the only
meaning or it needs to be limited to
buses otherwise I think we're going to
if passes we're going to end up with Y
that's okay so I'll I'll hear what
others have got to say and then I'll ask
I'll ask Tom what he thinks good some I
move in a second Michael uh through
yourself chair I just need to ask
Council to step back a little bit and um
actually go through the process of
accepting the hearings um approvals as
well and actually then accept the report
we haven't we've jumped to the
recommendations without actually going
through accepting the report so I just
want us to
we can accept the hearing component and
then move into the report and then you
can um Step into the recommendations
happy to move the
recommendations thank you all those in
favor
carry so uh rang and your hand up yeah
look um can you get back to the screen
you had with option one option
two oh no no sorry I thought we were
back we've done you yeah we're all good
just back to that option one option two
option two it says access from 11 Street
yeah now buses the the the consulted on
option and the only option I've seen
shows the arrow pulling up in 11 Street
doesn't access it doesn't access the
actual site of the hotel so it's
basically pulling alongside living
street so is that what we're still
talking
about option two the option two
pulls up alongside Lon Street it doesn't
access Vehicles can access the car park
yep no no that's not the one the
consultation document um yeah so they
just pull up and 11 straight is that
right a Vehicles can access the car park
like a normal car but a bus there's no
way it can turn come in 11 Street try
and do a turn and get back out again
it's physically impossible so I'm just
ruling that out yeah
Russell you help me out there it can't
it can't do that that's why that's why
we're talking about option one sure
correct Y is that correct right just
make sure option two is that as per the
consultation document which showed a bus
parking option on Liv Street yeah thanks
that's
it coming their side Ellen
finally um quick question you talking
about option one and option two here but
you've actually got three options yep
now from what I'm understanding if I
look at option three isn't that closer
to what everybody's talking about which
is a hybrid um area for pedestrians and
for
vehicles you got option a b and c one
two and three C is from the rear of the
hotel no one suggesting amending it
hybrid public realm with Tool Bus access
to the rear of hotel and allocate up to
15.4 blah blah blah is that not really
what you're talking about for option one
no no the rear of the hotel was the one
we consulted on where the public was
shown option three came off the present
through the middle and through right the
space in the middle the right away
that's a private right away and then
round to the front of the room and that
wasn't deemed to be suitable second part
of the question is now by having a a um
a option one point whatever you want to
call it are you not getting into the
actual design as part of this shouldn't
we just be voting on the fact that you
have access for vehicles or
not a one and two access for vehicles or
not and then after we get some
design stuff from staff then we vote on
how it's actually going to look as
opposed to voting on how it's going to
look now well I guess the issue is the
issue of Transport through wner or not
so in fact no no have you got options
again hang on counselor if you want to
ask a question give me the chance to
time to ask question you've asked me
whether we should just be voting on
transport through or not yes what I'm
saying to you is that given the workshop
we had yesterday and the one we've had
previously there is some degree of uh
wanting to retain some of the features
or functions of walking the place which
one does not allow for in some ways and
and mind you can't make decisions at a
workshop understand it um do you not
think that you're still getting into the
Realms of design I mean today's initial
thing was access or no access and now
you're getting into design saying well
let's leave the clock in the middle
let's go left and let's go right that's
design isn't that something that should
come back to us in the future well
that's something I don't agree with so
you'll have the option to vote for
option one or or the alternative which
is one a so so this amendment that I'm
putting you you can vote against that
and if you do then we're at option one
that was initially consulted on Grant
yeah thanks M just I think probably we
maybe need to come up with some wording
which we're trying to reflect through
that and it's a little bit to Alan's
point where we're looking at allowing
access off the street through walkner
place what that type of vehicle is
whether it's strictly a bus or it's a
mixed Arrangement and how that is is is
going to probably come back to Russell's
table around what's the advice they
would give us around
you how a mixed a mixed um approach to
traffic access through walk price could
work so we need to get hung up on the
vehicle thing um can we just call for
the global piece of the V vehicle access
um and and that may come back that it's
just for buses from Russell's table from
for advice to us at some stage in the
process or do we have to so um an answer
to that is we'd like to make decisions
today that guide the yeah the design
process and we need to get on with this
it's not a matter of catering for Jeff
Thompson and his hotel um any hotel
being bu built by anybody needs to be
serviced in a timely manner yeah so we
don't have time on our side so we need
to move fairly quickly um hence ideal to
have a decision today happy I'll talk to
Tom in a minute after listen to
everybody else about whether we reword
the word vehicle that's what you want um
I'm not hell bent on that
um I'll come back to you Tom any other
yeah TR sorry just to clarify by
choosing option one we aren't ruling out
the possibility of not having the clock
there at some
stage is that is that what what it's
saying I mean it says that it's
retaining the clock and the um columns
yes not but it doesn't but it doesn't
say what will happen is that correct
yeah I see your hand coming up Alex so
um my view of that is that um we've been
asked by um members of the public so
consultation pares and we can argue all
day if we want to about whether that was
representative of what's in the
community or not but I guess it's
reasonable to assume a starting point
could be to retain the clock and to use
the space either side if we get a six
months or a year down the track and
we've beautified the clock cuz it is
pretty ugly at the moment and we have
some uplighting on it and it's still
doesn't suit our needs then I've been
advised by staff that we can still take
the clock out but it would be a council
decision to do so and it would take away
the emotions of buses and everything
else because if you took the clock out
the bus would still go through and the
foot paaths would still go through so
that doesn't preclude us getting to that
decision somay not trying to kick it
down the track i' like to get a firm
position today thank you Alex thank you
worship um I say this is a really um
fantastic compromise from um I guess
everybody in any way any of the
submitters that we've looked at um any
of the feedback that we've had in our
digital channels um it's really clear
that there's seems to be the two really
strong sides of the story here where
they really how Bon retaining it in the
same situe that it is now or people are
happy to see uh the livelihood of um
East Street West actually you know come
to fruition so with what we what you've
got up there that sets the intention
that we have said that y we will retain
the the clock structure but we'll be
allowing vehicle use in a shared space
um manner not to disimilar to what we've
got in es Street to allow for that
function to occur um I think what we've
got there with your amendment is
fantastic um and allows for everything
to happen it doesn't preclude us from
going through to the design phase in The
Next Step but it um it's yeah based on
what we've consulted on it shows in our
and um option one that that that traffic
will be allowed through there but it
doesn't stop those those Hospitality
spaces or those shed spaces from
thriving
either thank you for that um so and and
this is a a bit of a piece um um um
issue between the two options I mean I
was very in favor of one I am still very
in favor of one it looks up to me
personally I take the whole structure
out and recreate a street further down
um but got to listen to what you
Community
saying so I think that's some Middle
Ground um I don't want us to get to a
stage where we give
um Russell and John who's sitting in the
back of the room as well hiding away um
a mixed message on what we want them to
do with the design the if if the option
is one a for argument sake we want them
to go away and know that that's what the
option is not to come back with some
designs that change that option and we
come back to another consultation
process because people are crying out
for a decision on it and that's not Jeff
there's others as well anybody else
right Tom oh no sorry Leslie oh sorry
Leslie thank you so uh since we seem to
be discussing the matter at this point
yeah I just want to say that the
suggested change to the
wording is actually just
overemphasizing a preference for option
one before we have voted on it so it's a
compromise but it's a compromise that
saying the best option is to allow
vehicles through and here's a way that
we can put a bit of compromise to save
some of the other features that people
said they liked about walk in the place
um I still believe the genuine decision
to make today is whether or not as a
council we agree
with vehicle access at all through wner
place my own preference and I declare it
now um is that we talked about people
first EXT connection that is still my
preference I am not as as a first
preference a believer in the vehicle
access option um even with the suggested
compromise I think we got a clear steer
from our submitters and we do have to
take our submitters seriously I'm sorry
I do not buy into the argument that
because we only had 173 submitters
therefore that can somehow be discounted
or given less weight than it deserves
the fact is we had 173 who were prepared
to make their submissions make their
feelings clear of that the majority and
I'll say 86% were against option one
some of them preferred option three some
of them indicated they would be happy
with option two or three but clearly
there was a preference there for option
two the people first
connection and even with the compromise
I am not convinced that the people of
inago were telling us they were happy to
have vehicle access through wner place
so I'm sorry but my preference remains
at option two and I believe that the
suggested amendment to option one at the
moment um which I will be forced to vote
against um does not clarify the main
decision we are making today which is do
we allow vehicle access or not it merely
gives a a
an extra bit of compromise to option
one so um so um I don't understand where
you're coming from but I respect your
views um I guess whichever way this vote
goes whether we're voting on one or one
a we are still going to get to the final
decision of do we put Vehicles be it
buses or anything else through walking
the place yes or no and people are
polarized on that and that we'll get to
that regardless of whether they have one
or one a so to those that want two or
three um then you I don't know how
you're going to vote on one 1A I'm just
trying to get some Middle Ground um and
if you want to abstain because you don't
agree with it then you don't agree with
it all I'm doing for the people that are
prepared to open or partially open up S
Street lower s Street I'm giving them an
alternative option to consider
Ellen you keep talking about 1A and um
one I don't see a one and a 1 a up here
anymore I don't where are the um all I
see is a 1 a yep so where is option one
which is just open for open you know and
then the designers come back to us so
I've already clarified that but I'll do
it again for your benefit um we had one
on the table which is what we consult on
I've moved an amendment because I think
there is some Middle Ground which is
what we have discussed in workshops
previously as 1A so I'll will refrain
from doing that I'll just referred to an
amend we're going to vote on your
Amendment first yeah correct and then if
it's voted down it's voted down then we
vote on one versus another option
absolutely who El
do fresh just want to clarify um what
you see ly which is accurate but
86% is how many
people there were 173
submissions but we're not
86% against so of the subm missions
102 selected option two or three the
majority of those
102 um 16 specifically selected option
three but several of those implied that
that actually meant to select option two
31 said they did not favor any of the
options at all
23 of the
173 went for option one
that's that's a clear 86% who did not
select option one anyone listening what
the numbers
were before I come to you Tom I'll
clarify position as well so for those
here last term uh we had a a museum uh
consultation as well and the two options
that were put in front of the committee
were one strengthen the pyramid Museum
we've currently got and reopen it the
other option was to wait and see think
of other options we went outside those
two options and voted for a new Museum
the overwhelming majority wanted the
rest strengthening about
85% the other issue is I guess as
counselors we all know that you while
you listen to consultations you don't
always have to abide by them classic
example is if we had had a public
consultation on the vaccine mandate that
came up when it was a year or two ago
given that outside on the street there
were probably three or four or 500
people we would have got I suspect a
huge volume of people that were opposed
to vaccines submitting and the rest
would have set sign given our preferred
option was to have the Mandate because
we' have to declare that that doesn't
mean that we would have tipped over that
mandate I I
think um so I think councelor CRA H the
nail right on the head um
we had two options that you could you
know that um we s consultation on um a
lot of the people who spoke to us you
know both in terms of formal submissions
and in terms of you know social media
and conversations that we've had talked
about trying to preserve the Heritage
aspects of walkner place a very key part
of that um being the clock
so I I think what you have proposed um
and the rewarding of that is a very good
compromise and there's nothing wrong
with compromise I think it's a very very
good
compromise now the only the only thing I
would say though is that if we think
about the reasons why we contemplated T
buses being able to crosswalk the place
was the difficulty um even you know
extreme difficulty of buses been able to
turn in es Street West so in other words
if we um had brought them up from Le
Street and a Street West very very
difficult to turn so we we agreed that
for two buses um one agreed but we
agreed that an option for two there
would be to bring T buses to the walk
the place and that way they would not
have to turn they'd be able to continue
in oneway Street basically and and there
this the same does not apply to taxes
delivery Vans and so forth to me they
can very easily just turn off lean
Street up in air Street West and you
know turn around and go back at the same
way I just don't think there's a need so
well I I know um you change of the work
two buses to Vehicles the must have I
never actually picked up that point
before I seconded it um I just don't
think it's necessary it's the key issue
is T buses that's the problem now I
cannot think of pretty much any
pedestrian area anywhere that does not
allow some vehicle access they all do so
by going down this track I don't think
we're doing anything different than most
people would do I mean if if I think
about how we
access um outside this building how we
access the rear of the Civic
Theater um to to bring in props and so
forth to bring in trucks and buses
through there is basically a gap in a
concrete wall um which drives over the
pavement to any that Gap it's almost
exactly analogous to what we're talking
about here so I don't think we're
breaking you ground if you excuse the
pun so I I would I still support the
amended words after buses y but I would
leave the word to buses did because I
think that's where they need us yep so
we agree on that Tom so Michael if you
can reword that out take the word
vehicle out and assert the word buses
which restricts it any further
discussion just on this amendment not on
the general vote that goes thereafter
ringing it it's not on the amendment but
it is on it is critical about option
three because I don't need Russell's
help here is that option three puts in
danger critical Telecom infrastructure
that runs underneath the pathway that
the bus bus would take so basically what
I'm saying it also has D it right away
um there's some things built into that
access so I would actually like to see
option three removed because I don't
want people going down that path and
using their vote on three when they
could have gone one or two because three
uh Russell do you agree is not really an
option Mr chair Mr May to my knowledge
option three is not currently
technically available to the
developer yeah I just didn't want yeah
okay I'll come back at the minut
roving
Bri Mr May I've thought about this long
and hard and really have taken on board
what our submit have said and I at the
stage I also as like Ley don't support
Option 1 a um from what I can determine
we've been asked do we support bus
access through wner through through wner
place or not um
and we were asked by our submitters and
also the people that posted on our
social media pages to keep this as a
pedestrian access only um to and as we
talked about yesterday to give people a
reason to go there because we're focused
so much on our new city center um and
for all the reasons that lesle has that
she can't support option 1A I'm also
very strongly of the same decision yep
so so I'm more in favor of auction two
yep um respect your riew I just want you
to consider one thing I'm not here to
I'm not here to convince you yeah but if
you vote against one the amendment we
will come down to one or two in the
original forms and that will take away
the option of having bus if one kicks in
MH that will change the
landscape because we don't have the
ability to keep the clock up I
completely understand that that's okay
that's fine Barry
yes um like councelor soapa and councel
bond I feel that this doesn't actually
Advance the cause of making the decision
about bus or no bus this is just about
clock or no clock
um we are talking about quite a major
change to the use of a space that people
whether they actively use it or not
obviously in the submission phase felt
strongly about it wasn't just the clock
that they felt strongly about it was the
space as a whole and the opportunities
that the space provided the fact that we
have not over um a period of 30 odd
years invested in making the space more
up toate more attractive to the change
in society's uses for space is on is on
us as a city not on the
space what we're offered now as a
challenge to
make better use of the space including
listening to the people who who see
value in the clock and the mechanism and
the historic nature but most principally
towards the um whole conversation that
is
around making pedestrians and people who
do not use Motor Vehicles all the time
as important in the inner city as the
vehicles now we've made a step towards
it but when we agreed to let cars back
into es Street people suddenly
discovered that they actually liked an
es street with no not many cars so let's
not make that same mistake again letting
anything like a bus access that space I
think will preclude us from forbidding
motorbikes or Tock tocks or anything
that is motorized going down there and
is that really um making it people
friendly it's making it bus friendly
it's making it tourist friendly perhaps
but is it making it the people of the
city friendly and that was the I believe
is what we really went out and asked
about the buses the bus access was only
part of it how do we make wner place an
interactive important part focus of our
city again so on that basis I would have
to agree with councelor so and bond I
will not be supporting Option 1 a or one
well just not that I get to vote I just
going to mention that uh Alex you're the
last comment on this before I put the
vote um thank you your worship um I
think we're getting a little bit
confused around um the impact that
allowing you know guess maximum of about
five or six buses for 2 minutes through
uh a shared space will actually have the
remaining 24.5 hours of the day will be
totally dedicated to retain aining the
intention of what wner place has and
always would stand for well and if if we
manag to retain the clock as well what a
beautiful centerpiece that we'll be able
to refresh in the center of our city I'd
also like to point out that um 172
submitters uh of our populace of 57,000
people of inago was
0.3% of the voices of our people so if
they're not yelling at us considerably
loudly than they are that they want to
retain in this space and they they're
not happy with what we're considering
then they they they would have made
their voices very well known like they
did around several other sagas that
we've got gone through like the museum
over the last couple of years um you
know me you know I'm all about shed
spaces and pedestrianization and in a
city play and getting people out and
about but I don't think that allowing
buses through there for you know 5
minutes is actually going to impact
those objectives and outcomes that um
our submitters like John who's sitting
in the gallery there were talking about
uh getting those outcomes for activating
those spaces I really don't see that
letting them through for two minutes is
going to have that much of an impact on
it and in fact we actually with this
Redevelopment Revitalize the space so um
your worship it's clear I I will be
voting for your Amendment um and I hope
that others would consider that too um
the point of order y Mr chair uh you
just mentioned a very scary word that
you're going to put it to the vote now a
lot of people have spoken about the main
subject the substantive yep peace now
I'm worried that this vote is going to
end it and we're gone but are you just
voting on this deliberation between 1 a
and
one no no you voting because we haven't
had the opp Slow Down slow down he's
he's done a point of order so I'll
clarify for you we're only voting on the
amendment that I put at this stage the
am not on the main main options just
clarifying an amendment to option one
only okay no no that's cool I just need
to you now we have just one minor well
not so Min procedural matter and I've
missed in the agenda uh item four which
is the minutes of the hearing of the
city block west held on Thursday the
24th of
October Michael's giving me the thumbs
up so if I don't
pass that first I'm in trouble so
somebody would like to move that Grant
and Barry thank you any discussion about
those minutes no all in favor I I
carried right back to the original
position which is I'm putting the vote
now by put up by myself and seconded by
Tom that the wording changes for option
one as we've got up in the phase and I'm
going to do a show hands don't want
record names but certainly want to be
clear on on that I'm not just doing on
eyes only so all those those in favor of
that Amendment if you could raise your
hand
carried so now we are back to um the
issue record my vote against yes I can
do that and Ria and Leslie both opposed
and Peter as well thank you now we come
back to the issue of options one 2 and
three and based on
um um Russell's advice is that option
three is not really available to us but
but again I we could leave it there
unless somebody's desperately needing to
vote on it given it's not available to
us I don't see any procedural issue of
that but I'm open to having that removed
if somebody would like to remove move
the we remove it okay so I've got a
second to with Rea anybody like to have
some discussions in relation to removing
options three see done excellent all
those in favor I I carried the final
part of this jigel puzzle is options one
and
two and I'll put option
one Tom's I'll move yep and Grant
seconders and we'll do it by way of a
show of hand so people know exactly and
I'm happy if you somebody wants it done
by names as
well division uh point I believe that
there were um some people including uh
Council poer who wanted to speak correct
oh sorry yeah no no we haven't I also
want to speak we we were talking about
the options for one sure and then some
people have used the opportunity to
speak okay and sneak it in but sure you
know I'd like to actually Absolutely
I'll open up discussion before we have
the vote on options one and two rangy oh
okay right um just noting that in the
consultation option one actually does
say in the consult cons a document
reconstructed Clock Tower location gives
more prominence to retained Heritage
buildings but that's in the
consultation so what I have to say is
really in
1989 City's Architects along with the
council had a vision to put Vitality
into the city center now what the place
was a bold attempt to achieve this
needed vitality and visit visitor
experience I mean I actually salute them
for this bold step and the decision to
make it happen however those decisions
that drove that creation of walk to
place and shutting off East Street West
were based on the knowledge and
information available at the time and
what was happening in the city what was
currently happening in the city now 34
years
on this Council now has a new 150 room
distinction hotel as a catalist to
actually revisit the the relevance of w
place and the use of E Street West now
again 34 years on Council will be
required to make an informed decision
but the landscape has changed
dramatically we now have City Block we
got the langlands hotel we got uh
pedestrian vehicle sharing of lower and
Dawn lower esque and Dawn we got the hwr
tower so these are all
relevant and in influencing our next
steps and the way we move forward now
we've got two options up there one would
have buses deliver visitors to a Smart
sheltered hotel entrance and the second
option would have them dumped on the
curb in 11 Street also do we want these
visitors to have welcoming access to our
brand new city I've just talked about or
do we want them navigating a concrete
steel barricade that actually would act
as the Berlin Wall now
what would a city with heart want for
such a visitor
experience as it was 34 years ago go
this Council needs to be bold so I
am without doubt going for option one
yep so um as I said in my uh email out
you this morning we are not going to
have a cross the table bouncing of ideas
I'm going to work my way around the
table and you get one chance to say what
you need to say on the options one and
two so um P you and if you don't want to
say something you can just default my
pass on I suppose where I'm sort of like
I mean I totally agree with what um
lesli as well as where has sort of
brought to the table but I suppose I
can't understand why it's not being
dropped off at at the side of the street
and Liv Street there was never no design
for an entry or from the
developer on what that could look like I
mean if you're going to enter off Liv
Street you can enter off the side and
then continue South when I look at going
through Wagner place you're dropping off
on E Street and then going around North
cuz there's no way a bus could turn to
go
south so it it's
it's yeah so for me it's coming back to
people first in the
street
Steve um I think I mentioned in a
previous Workshop that I was um
struggling with this decision is one of
my first big ones um and so I've talked
to a lot of people and I appreciate
everyone that's submitted I think that's
a great part of our process um but I
I've just also been really excited about
the opportunity in front of us to to be
bold and connect our city and and um
welcome these these tourists into to our
city in a meaningful way but also
provide something really special for our
community and um I think councelor
Campbell and cracket really summed up my
excitement for this opportunity and it's
a it's a a really great compromise that
shows I think we've listened to our
community in the submission process so
um I'm excited about option one thank
you Darren given that you sit right
opposite I uh am supporting option
one and in doing so
recognizing the significant changes that
have gone on in the city over an even
longer period of time than 34 years I
think one of the things that that
Council of Binger didn't mention was the
fact that the internet has arrived since
then and that's had a market
change on our community and how we do
business and how we associate and also
made a significant change in placemaking
MH um and that's at the heart of of what
a lot of the passion around wner place
has been and I think some of the
multi-use spaces that have been
developed elsewhere recognizing a few of
the climactic challenges that come with
that part of town will allow
for a nominal incursion of of the
occasional vehicle but still leave a
space where people have
precedence as they do in es Street
actually when you cross the road car has
to
stop and actually it's been like that
for a long time despite a few drivers
not noticing the sign that they went
past um I think it's important that we
do pause to to look at some of the other
issues around the columns but uh the
retention
of the Clock Tower is is something that
people have spoken passionately about
and I think there will be a slightly
different Civic space or or no public
space I think a Civic space is something
else we have to address at some other
point but the prominence of this on
State Highway 6
is is not
insignificant um but I don't see it
as a loss of the current amenity as much
as an amendment to what it
is thank you Alex um thank you for the
seconding B at the Cherry but as um
Council pager rightfully put out I've
already sort of seen my piece before I
probably should
have so technically I have spoken before
as well but however I was advised by
your email that when it came to this
part of the thing that man would have
the right to speak so I want to go back
to the fact that this and as I mentioned
in the workshop is possibly the closest
space we have to where the original
Walker Landing space was and
where in the beginnings of this as a
city um the sailing ships came so the
connection between wner place and the
railway station that arrival and
departure space is actually a connection
that is I think quite important um when
I've been considering this and I've been
looking at the um all the historical
Connections in particularly the role of
the wers in this thing there was
something I was unaware of I spoke last
night to a 92-year-old who told me about
Mr wner and his role as May being there
at the departure of every troop train
and the arrival home of every
Soldier during World War II not in His
official capacity just as in his
capacity as a caring human being
something that was quite well known at
the time now to my shame I did not know
that although I have spoken about his
generosity and is
philanthropy this space is not the space
that Mrs wner invested in um this space
is not going to be the space that the
citizens invested in in 1988
1989 this is going to take away some of
the opportunities that they
have had and we are not yet offering
them something to replace that so whilst
I recognize that the majority will
probably go um to the vision of tourists
and buses and the um the development of
a hotel facility I really want to remind
people that buses can come and go and
tourists may come and go but the people
of this place are the people who came
here whether they were came here a
thousand years
ago 200 years ago 80 years ago or in the
case of the very your staff member 6
weeks ago the person who presented
earlier today we continue to welcome
people but who are the people who choose
to stay and where is their place in this
conversation so I would like to implore
you all to think about the people who
have chosen to stay and invest in this
place and keep wner place as a place
that is connected to the city and is
intrinsically the heart of our
city thank you Leslie thank you M Clark
so I've spoken before but as I spoke
against um the amendment I'm taking the
chance to speak now on the substantive
issue um yes it was a brave move to
establish wner place in
1989 and many things have changed that
time since that time and I would just um
like to remind people that another of
the things that has changed is the
attitude of all counil towards
pedestrianized
spaces we don't have to build our cities
around vehicles to or buses or any other
vehicles any longer and most councils
now recognize that so I would just
remind people that that the decisions of
this Council are not ruled by what is
best for tour of usses or indeed any
vehicular traffic the decisions of this
Council in my view are around what is
best for the rate payers and residents
of inago and if part of enhancing that
is to support our tourism industry that
is good but overall I am Guided by what
I believe is best for the rapers and
residents of the carago and what they
have given me to understand is what they
wish at the moment as far as I'm
concerned wner place was
quintessentially a place for people to
go to enjoy to have protests at to sit
and enjoy food trucks or whatever
entertainment might be on to make use of
the stage to be there because you're on
the way to the library and it's a good
place to sit and check that your library
books were the ones you meant to choose
um to be there with your kids to use the
very good toileting and other facilities
we have established there to go to the
restaurants it was a place for people to
go for many reasons which people have
told us they value as residents and rate
payers of the city of
inago I believe on that basis alone that
the only option I can vote for is option
two and that is what I intend to do the
people first s connection to the city
center in the heart of in the cargle I
believe is still in wner place we have
not offered an
alternative if we take away wner place
and say Vehicles can go through wner
place and it will not be three or four
buses a day for a couple of minutes it
will be more than that because once we
open it to Vehicles other vehicles will
pressure to go
through we have not suggested in this
taking away of the essence of wner place
that we have an alternative as a council
that we are offering we have not said we
are creating or have another heart to
replace the wner place we are taking
away until we do that option two is what
I shall vote for thank you thank you
Peter thank you uh look we must listen
to the people
86% and what I hear we're not most of us
around here some of us are not taking
any notice of that look why would you
open up a very dangerous wind tunnel
area the ones that are remember what it
was like was the most dangerous place in
inago city until what the place was
built why would you open up that it was
so bad it was blowing people over uh and
the wind still comes predominantly from
the West I explained it yesterday I
won't explain it again today but it's
only for one bus a day why would you
open up a a dangerous wind tunnel for
one bus today maybe no buses tomorrow
two buses the next day then there may be
three or four days with no buses look
the gifted land uh that the Walker
family gave to in Vago they'd be
horrified now and so were their
relations and friends that
it it it served as a purpose by blocking
that wind out and as I explained
yesterday it blocks a lot of that wind
going up to isk Street you going to open
that up we're going to have problems on
our hands what's going to happen in say
a few years time that land that Mr
gastello gifted the city the man from
odara someone may come up with a
brilliant idea oh we'll do something
else we've got Mr gell man good why look
what message are we sending to the
public I was talking to a group of
elderly people just last Thursday uh
when I say elderly in their 80s and 90s
and one fell told me H's wife are
thinking were thinking of when they go
to leave a bit of money to the city
council to put for for a very good cause
or use he said what some of those
councilors are thinking about now is put
them off compl completely so what
message are we sending out there look no
busers for me thank you very
much thank you baring yeah I I support
option one um I don't believe there's
going to be a lot of vehicles go through
that um and we can if we stay with their
buses the two buses then we can stop
other vehicles from going through there
um yeah that's my anyway I'm I'm happy
enough we're we're leaving the clock
there um so we've compromised here and
yeah that's my opinion on that yeah
thank you
Tom um I'm going to add a little bit to
Evelyn's story I I I'm quite passionate
about history and Heritage as well and I
I've been speaking to people about this
thing too and one thing I found out I
don't know whether anybody else this
room knows this I never knew it but
Mabel walkner actually had to buy the
land to donate it to the city it wasn't
owned by
walkner um and I was actually talking to
the person who sold it to her right all
those years
ago and mayel walk's vision was for a
green space in the center of the city it
was not for what was actually built what
she wanted to build was a little Park
actually in that space and I think you
know there's some disappointment about
the fact that it ended up a bit here
concrete J jungle um I think there is an
opportunity through what we're talking
about to revitalize and
refurbish that area um I think it will
be better as a consequence of what we
were talking about at the moment it was
built 39 years ago however long ago it
was and it looks as though it's never
been touched since it's a
rusting relatively you know is in very
poor condition and it badly the tree
fation including the
I I think 5 years down the track um if
there are buses that cross here and I'm
sure as Barry said there's ways we can
stop other vehicles if if there are
buses Crossing there for 5 minutes a day
as Alex said then 5 years from now we
wonder what the first was about to be
honest I I think I think we can make
walkner place a better tribute to
Abraham walkner than it is today by
refurbishing
it
thank you right yeah thanks CH can I
suggest to Peter as good sir would like
to answer may maybe the museums a good
cause um just with respect to the
consultation um I thought that was a
very valuable process and sort of
dissected not only the submissions but
equally the people I've spoken to and
what's come through is the rich history
in this area and even as Evelyn's
pointed out you know the first landing
site so what better way to welcome
people to our city than in a place place
like that it's just about how we tell
that story came through very strongly
around the clock and I think with what
we've got in option one which I'll be
voting for we we can look to retain that
and I think that adds to that but
equally the other point I think we need
to think about is economic development
you know I've got um family that are
returning from University and they're
struggling to get jobs over the holidays
we've lost 200 jobs in the city because
of H and JS and here's an opportunity
that's probably going to employ 100 odd
people and some of those will be
temporary in part time and it's about
economic development and we we've got to
find a balance and you know those people
that work in that hotel they will be
either tenants of landlords or they will
be house owners and will be rate payers
and we need to focus and provide
opportunity and look to partner with the
hotel and this investment in a way that
there's a level of compromise and I
think option one provides that and
that's the way I'll be voting thank you
thank you Mr Mayor um I mean a lot of
people have already um said the the twos
and the the frows and the and the cons
but what I wanted to um let us be
remindful of is that we're told that a
history DET takes what our future looks
like and that the future and what that
looks like for tomorrow um I feel that
this counil particularly is forgetting
that and what we're choosing to allocate
in terms of buses um I'm very strong in
listening to those submits when they
said that they require us to have a
pedestrian only area I still support
that
while so get the economic value of what
this can bring to our city um I'd like
us to find a more even
um ability to do that without taking
away what the people of this city have
told us um I understand too and support
what Tom has said that
the the U Mel wner did purchase that
land and had a completely different
space but I do believe that we
do still have the
potential an option to to beautify what
in the place and to make it more Greener
I don't think that we haven't gotten
into the design yet um of that um I
can't support option one on the basis of
the various submitters and what they
brought to this table and the passion
and history that they brought to us I
cannot and will not ignore
that yeah thank you
Ellen I didn't have a hand up you just
want to talk to me
sorry bearing in mind that um we aren't
going to open it up completely um then I
will be supportive of op for option one
um I think I agree with Grant I mean
we've got to look at the economic side
of um things people are prepared to put
this sort of investment into our
community I mean we should be doing
things to assist also bearing in mind
what Ian was saying before when you look
at in
vagle um 34 years ago I haven't done my
son 34 years ago I think he said um
there wasn't much happening down below
there but there is now you've got the
Old Railway Hotel you've got the railway
station itself which as we all know is a
historic building even though it was
built in 1975 and then now you're going
to have a 150 person hotel which is the
biggest accommodation provider in the
viago without without a doubt possibly
escot maybe bigger but um so to me it's
a we bit of an no-rain I'd like to see y
stre continued personally the way we
have y stre at the moment um we some of
us walk through there before and I think
we might have been on the street for 10
minutes we've seen two cars so to me
it's working perfectly as a pedestrian
Precinct with car access available I'll
be quite happy to see the speed limit
lowered um on that bit of a street as
well just to redu cars even more
possibly but um if lower Street would
look something similar to that um Carri
that same concept through I I think I'd
be very happy because then to me it
married it up I mean you got State
Highway Six going through the middle but
but at the end of the day State Highway
6 is really just the main street of
inago you know I don't think people I
mean you go that way to Riverton or to
Queenstown but it's just the main street
of inago so um the fact that you got da
in the middle of a two nice bits doesn't
matter I'm happy to leave the columns
here I think the columns should be
retained if they can be it's a great
sort of um thing to um make the brisan
Crosser look Crossing look safer um and
if I had my way I'd probably have access
in two directions through uh lower es
street but at that much reduced speed
probably keep it for buses only but um
in saying that you know with the
compromise of the clock I'm I'm happy to
have the clock but I would have been
happy to move the clock as well but it
should be it should be retained
maintained um so if it stays there and
you've got access there
um it probably sort of meets what I sort
of see as the vision um to continue the
prosperity and growth of Ino because I
mean to be honest the face of ofo has
changed in the last 5 years dramatically
and and I'd like to see that continue
thank you thank you i' just like to note
that this is the first time ever you've
talked about reducing a speed Li that is
correct but on this occasion I think
suitable yeah we'll know that
Trish um I am for option one and I'd
like to just mention two things well
there's been a lot of talk about um
Mabel wner in what she's done in and
what she's given the city and there's no
question that she has or what she
offered the plaque that's in wner place
talks about Abraham wner it doesn't
mention May what so obviously in the
past the councilors didn't get that
right um I'm not saying they should have
but we just need to remember that we're
trying to do something that's smart and
we need to try and move forward I'd like
to acknowledge the leadership um from
the May in bringing listening to the
submitters and bring bringing this
amended number one I think we've come to
an excellent compromise um we we we
listened we may have to make changes or
not but at the moment um we're doing the
best that we can given what we put
out okay I'm the last one to comment on
it um as you probably know I was keen
and supportive of option one before it
was amended so I would have just taken
the whole the whole lot out and just had
a One Way straight through similar to
what we've got yesterday um but I will
um bow to the interim amended one
because I think that's a compromise that
that satisfies the community
um I'm I'm not sure I agree with uh
cities going towards pedestrian what I
see around certainly in places like Tao
um and our nearest neighbor which is
Queenstown have gone away from
pedestrian only to Shared spaces so
shared spaces means um a predominance of
pedestrian traffic but with very slow
vehicle traffic coming through very slow
and I think that works well in both
Queenstown and in too where I've looked
as well and so I'll be supporting option
one um so somebody Toms moved one Grant
so uh do we want it on a show of hands
or do we want does anybody want it
recorded which way the votes are going
which is a division
no call for a division okay just purely
on a show of hands all those in favor of
option
one one two three four you got are you
up r no you're still one two three four
five six 7 8 nine 10 so that's 10
three thank you for you parti please
record one two please three three
opposed or we to have them recorded
against Russell for you and for John um
just a little bit of side comment for me
it gives you the green light to get on
with the uh
infrastructure uh great if you could
come back with some plans that might
scope for us how that looks with the
traffic going through being mindful that
one of the issues we have is that
Heritage building that has The Veranda
over the top and how I understand we
have plenty of time to get a consent
through to have that removed in fact
it's questionable whether it was
actually part of the original design
anyway um and on a personal level if we
could tidy up the clock be it painted in
a very neutral color that doesn't make
it too predominant given that we want
people to look past the clock certainly
from the backside and maybe some up
lighting at night time would be really
neat okay y so we've also got
um some recommendations on um nine
is it 9 9 10 and 11 12 oh sorry 12 you
have to move it for
me and 12 so we got three more
recommendations in there some you like
to move I'll move those Alex thank you
and Darren any discussion about those
three options those three
recommendations absolutely none all
those in
favor carried
sorry oh sorry just point of
clarification sure um in the discussion
about the port CER that is going to
intrude onto what is technically the
road space is that correct that I can't
answer yes is correct people the back of
the room so y so in that respect then
that is also where we need to be mindful
that that should not be an impact upon
the right players that that should be an
impact upon the developer yeah look I I
it's encroachment on our public space
yes I I won't draw into that at this
stage I don't think I've heard nothing
from the developer that would indicate
that that the rate payers are paying for
any of the um potential infrastructure
impact around the building itself
Russell can you help me with that Mr
Mayor the um the porter share will have
a license to occupy which would which
would include the cost of the
development will be with the developer
yeah thank
you okay we got these to work through
here okay item six on
the got different
numbers Okay so we've got item five on
the
agenda which is the 2024 54 30-year
draft infrastructure
strategy this is your area
ringing yep sorry they just went off
line so the infrastructure strategy um I
mean I've read through and the alarming
bit to me and I've raised this with
Michel is the is is the money we're
putting aside
for uh the consense for the to
Wastewater discharges yep and um one's
in 2025 one's in 2029
now there's a big figure there $90
million now um what I just need some
clarity around is that the is that the
money set aside for the worst case
scenario where we don't get consent for
what we're currently doing and uh these
are plan b c and d coming into it or is
it just just a bit of
a is this we do get consent I just need
I can help you with that so the previous
government suggested to us uh well Dia a
did on behalf of um central government
that councils need to be aware that in
in the future going forward on these
consents that e would
oppose any land to got to get this right
water to water discharge so you wouldn't
be able to uh put it into a river or out
the sea that the uh preference was for
discharge to land and that councils
would need to find land B now some have
already done this as you'll be aware
some have not so the consent have not
come up um what I've asked the central
government which is very new so I don't
have an answer yet as you can imagine is
do they continue to have that position
that we should be going down that track
and there is a dollar cost as you can
see or whether or not um a council
should challenge that um if the consent
doesn't go their own way and would there
be government support to I guess put a
line on the sand about whether we can go
water to water which we currently do or
we go water to land which is the future
on it so I don't have an answer back on
that but they have said that they will
look at that no um I would agree with
you there because when you are talking
that amount of money yeah huge amount of
money then um if the consent is not
grounded then perhaps
litigation is an option considering
what's at stake sure and it's all based
around our Coastal plan and everything
and also the quality of the water we
would be discharging so if we got it to
a point that it was
drinkable but it was still objected
because of the cultural significance y
then you know uh and you look at the
impact on rate payers of rates going up
potentially a third you know you've got
to have there's got to be some
reasonable grounds
there for a but but it just what worries
me is is that it's all in the air and
we're just sitting there waiting for
this thing to come along and it's a bit
scary so they haven't appointed a
minister for internal affairs as you can
imagine that won't be too far away um
I've spoken to Penny about this and to
Simon who is potentially a ministering
this position and flagged that with them
by the time we get to the Clifton
consent the overall cost will be
somewhere around about 120 million
that's very
conservative given inflation Galloping
away for the next few years um but we
just don't have an answer to it yeah
yeah I guess we got to work on the
Russell's going to say something here I
guess we're going to have to work on the
assumption that we default to not being
able to get our consent the way it is at
the moment we signal that anyway Russell
um thanks Mr me what the infrastructure
strategy looks to do is to actually put
a 30-year Horizon and bring the
information from asset plans to get
gives some connection and Direction it
also links to the financial strategy So
within the infrastructural strategy the
options that we've listed are all there
but to actually also then develop and
inform the the long-term plan we have to
bring what the I guess best
understanding from the technical team
brings to the table to predict for the
next 10 years and they and they the the
options that are brought forward and are
in the in the draft budget for the AL so
all the options are there that list but
once again um by 2029 um some of those I
guess will need to be worked through the
the range of options with ewi where we
go um and that consenting is actually a
long a longer term process which will be
quite detailed and quite technical along
the way but what we're trying to show
within the strategy is what the likely
the most probable outcomes could be with
what we know at the moment now that
could change over the next few years and
such and such and accordingly the asset
plans and the infrastructure strategy
will need to be Revisited in due course
so I guess two things of that Russell um
again just having some overarching
discussions with the national
party uh pre-election and post elction
is um I think two issues I think there
will be a whole lot of consense will
will go through the process long before
we need to certainly with Clifton so we
we'll have an understanding where the
land lies um and the other issue I guess
is the issue of the overall three qus
impact and so uh National previously
said they're going to resend the uh
legislation but they will not resend the
water quality nor the um regulator
legislation so that'll still be there
and I think when I asked what does that
mean for us going forward it means that
we'll probably have to put in an annual
three Waters plan to show them what
we're doing heading towards this big
big amount of money at 30 years from now
um and I know that many councils will
not be able to afford that it'll just be
totally
unaffordable and so um they are
considering some things like a a sort of
um contestable fund that they may drive
out of taxes which allows some councils
to bid for money to help them with that
excise of getting the three water sld so
that that creates a landscape that we're
not sure about and there certainly are
some challenges ahead for this Council
and many
others but I guess that's what the
infrastructural strategy looks to um
document and highlight all that
Horizon okay Lesley thanks um Mr Mia you
may have partially answered this but I
thought I'd better check um when you and
councelor poton just spoke were you
implying that you might suggest the
inago city council as the test case no
no def def not no thank you I just
wanted to clarify that because members
of the public could very well have been
left with the impression that that's
what you had just suggested and I did
want that clarification when I spoke to
National members of parliament and some
from act as well I I said they may want
to um take on the issue if they don't
want you to to help a council go through
the process that wants to retain water
the water discharge it wouldn't be us
we're too far down the track um but it
could be some other Council and and I
just suggest them if you're going to do
that there could be quite a um a legal
cost for that Council that they might
want to assist with just to clarify for
all councils where the environment court
or wherever it lands um deter it to be
just just wanted that clarification to
be out on public definitely not not not
our Council no not at all thank you uh
Tom um it's not a that specific subject
but on the um the uh infrastructure
strategy itself
it seems to me that there's a couple of
you know what I think are really
important principles that I look at page
99 of board
books
um the paragraph that starts three
number three noncritical assets will be
allowed to operate to the expected lives
and and or Beyond recognizing that some
limited failures these assets may occur
uh before renewal and then over the
page paragraph six we will use risk
analysis business cases and other
Advanced modeling techniques to develop
and it goes on and and the point I want
to make is that that is exactly how
modern asset management works it should
be replacement should be done in
condition monitoring and or in you know
non-critical items let them run to
failure and that and I don't know how
much A change is in this strategy or
whether it's always been the way you've
treated it continues to be our focus and
I guess as we get I guess greater asset
maturity more information and our
systems grow over time so our knowledge
and our ability to deliver that um I
guess the challenge will always be is
where is that point we supposed to react
or where do you wait and that is where
the criticality is becoming a much more
I guess Focus point for for our teams to
be able to pick to pick that and and
know what's important yeah true again CH
I mean what I wanted to asking it's
probably more for the next paper and
Patricia than for you but if but if you
take that kind of approach to Asset
Management where you accept that if uh
you know something's 95 years old um
then you don't necessarily have to
replace it just because the manufacturer
said it should be replaced 100 years old
it's going to last longer than 95 years
if you take that kind of approach to the
asset management operating strategy I
would argue you should try take the
approach to um to
depreciation a a more aaral approach to
depreciation where you recognize that
something might be installed with a
20-year life but by the time you get to
the 18th or 19th year it's not going to
fa in the 20th year it's almost
certainly it's going to last longer than
that so I mean that's say and I will
talk to it when you know Patric does her
paper but I mean it's how you know
insurance companies think about us you
know when you're born
if you were born in 1952 when I was born
um 1950 when I was born then
um8 yeah your average expected life was
76 but if you get to my current age then
your average expected life is 86 or 76
because they're just as you get older
because you're a Survivor population you
never you never died at court death you
wer involved in a war you never got a
car crash and and you know my argument
would be that we should think about
taking approach to depreciation as well
as asset age it becomes a curve rather
than a straight line and and that might
be you know a a a way that we can mirror
in a in our financial um model exactly
what we're doing in our asset management
model which is that we don't
automatically assume in the 100th year
for 100 Year pipe be good replac
P so anyway so I can of mix the two
things up there but the fundamental
question I wanted to ask was whether it
was a new approach and I think from what
you've said Russell it's not completely
new but it's a direction of travel
that's that's correct and we do as we as
a pipe gets to the end of its life
revisit that and effectively continue to
extend that and revisit that pipe's age
um more frequently one of the things
that we're seeing in the
infrastructural um world is that a pipes
were only the first life cycle of a pipe
and often um the better deterioration
curves and those sorts of modeling are
often things where where assets have had
um like a 20-year life and with there've
been several Cycles over the time so you
can much more reliably product but
because we're a relatively new country
and we've only had one cycle of our
pipelines we are still in that learning
phase and um and you will have seen over
time with our Council some of our water
pipes with um had bearing age over the
last I guess 15 years or so where we've
had short lives longer lives shorter
lives and as more of the industry across
the whole country learns about what that
is for AC pipes and PVC pipes and those
things as we learn more it's being
applied um to our data on a the refresh
cycle of the revaluation of every three
years so that's one of the first things
we look at and saying is can we push the
life out even further and um I guess
predominantly to to say well if it's
going to last another 10 years well it
is going to last another 10 years what's
the risk and that strategy that's in
there really just says let's make sure
we understand which are the critical
pipes and let's not let them fall over
because I don't think we want to appear
like
Wellington um but if we get pipes that
have problems in a street it may well be
that you may say two or three bursts
before we actually react to that pipe as
a renewal so
so just as a reflection Russell I guess
from my end um end of life has a a
different terminology depending on who
you talk to so I sometimes hear people
say well it's it's got to the end of its
like CU it's 75 years when in fact it
could be very well 100 years but end of
life just means that's when we're going
to replace it so that's one issue the
other isue I just wanted to reinforce
what you said about a lot of it's
depending on where the pipes go because
some pipes are far more important than
others and I've heard heard the
discussion before from staff around um
renewals having regular renewals which
in some ways means regular work for a
contractor or contractors and if you
start dropping it off and and kicking
the ball down the track a little bit and
taking a bit of risk are you getting
yourself into a bit of a hole when you
need those contractors again because
they've got a drop off of work I guess
there's a couple of things in there the
first one is um we talk about remaining
useful life rather than end of life
so I guess that's a different focus on
it it's not actually when do you predict
it's how much do you think you've got
left which is actually probably a better
way to think you know what what have you
got left um in terms of the in terms of
the market and actually renewals that's
a that's actually us having a longer
term I
guess planned future for what we think
we're going to do work so the
contractors can gear themselves up if we
think we can suddenly go from a spend
one year and double it next year and the
whole industry respond and do it depends
on the scale of the work but if we're
doubling if we're going from $20 million
construction industry in terms of pipe
networks to $40 million it takes some
time for them to scale up and gear up to
make sure you actually get value for
money because I guess that's the balance
um so the industry is quite difficult
because it is a bit of a challenge
there's lots of and we suffer a little
bit from a smaller Market but it's also
they're looking at where the
profitability what's the easiest sort of
work to do um and other some other
Industries have less risk than um doing
pipe networks we have some quite easy
ground to dig up and then there's some
other ground that's really difficult so
it depends on what you where you are
what you're doing and which year um will
depend on how interested the contractors
are but it is a long-term prediction of
what we anticipate our future workloads
is really key to that market gearing up
and being being able to deliver and be
competitive because that's the piece we
want to make sure we're getting value
for money so what I was suggesting
wasn't that you increase the
contractor's work given what Tom said
about the curve as opposed to the
straight line we might and the initial
phase actually decrease their work and
if you did that which has some benefits
for us by kicking depreciation out and
then doing less work you then have a
trouble that when you want to get more
work done it's harder to back into the
industry so long as so long as we have a
long a long enough signal about where
that increase is going to occur then
your industry has an opportunity to
respond y okay thank you
AGR yeah it's more of a comment um than
anything else I think this paper and the
next one really crystallized the
challenge that's in front of us and
indeed all councils and I think it's
great that we've got it called out
really
clearly um so you know thanks to the
staff for putting it together in a
pretty Sy way but it shouldn't be lost
on us as councilors around what the
challenge is within this paper and the
next one in terms of finan and somehow
we' got to work it out is the
discussions just been had around it will
be around partnership with counil uh
with local contractors but equally I
think there's a really important part
for the new government to play in this
and you know we need to make the case
very strongly for their partnership with
us in this um because it can't just fall
to right payers and
and you're quite right if you look at
examples recently of Queenstown they've
got to their lending cap they can't
afford any more work I don't think renal
type work um they're just struggling
with it I mean while we think we've got
issues we're probably in one of the
better positions compared to a lot of
other councils but it's still we got to
be cognitive of
it um yes just through you
uh to Russell just you've referred to
inh here to Alternative water supply but
the Cory to that is the um water quality
that that water supply might bring but
also being recognition the recognition
of some of the issues that other
councils have had for example Queenstown
with um illness waterborne illness and
things like that how are we going to be
placed going forward in that in that
place because that's not really referred
to here I know to M are going to keep us
up to get to speed on that but are we
investing in improving our water
quality
um
treatment type things as new things are
being discovered and as new um concerns
are being raised so certainly a current
water supply is compliant which is a
huge advantage and certainly the
alternative water supply brings um I
guess that second part over the next
period to actually give us some
opportunity give us some I guess some
backdrop against should should an event
occur that our primary Supply isn't
available to us and that Supply will
also have um treatment that will
actually meet the requirements so that
would actually help us quite a lot
should should an event occur somewhere
on our Network that would limit the
current Supply because having a a sole
source of water at the moment
has that I guess that increased risk
profile that that's the only place we
get water from at the moment and should
something should an event occur whatever
it might be that would actually make
that a problem then we wouldn't have a
water supply so the alternative is
actually the piece that we can inject
treated appropriately treated water
compliant back into the network and be
able to deliver that gives us extra
capacity to deliver for other things but
it does mean that you've got a more
secure more robust water supply that's
resilient against I guess troubles that
might occur that we haven't necessarily
foreseen and we're keeping on investing
in upgrading our treatment processes and
that's that's the requirement that we
have to continue to meet and that's
thank we are fortunate in that situation
to be in the current position we are
okay any
other discussion on that no none would
somebody like to move the two
recommendations we have rangy thank you
up thank you all those in favor I I
carried next issue is the uh welcome
Patricia the
long-term Financial
strategy Let It Be noted that Andrew
doesn't have his cell phone up to his
ear
you want to take the paper read take the
paper read the the couple of things I
wanted to add is this the financial
strategy sits and interlinks with the
infrastructure strategy and that forms
the umbrella and is one of the core
functional pieces that we need for the
ltp but it
also provides the the guidelines or the
the guard rails for each of the activity
plans that you've set up it doesn't say
what we'll provide it says how we will
fund whatever the activity plans and
asset management plans say we are going
to provide to the community so it is in
a draft State because as we all know as
soon as I put a number in there in
relation to inflation or anything like
that it will change so it stays in a
draft state right through to um to June
but we do actually will go out and
consult on a number of pieces in it and
that all slipped to my mind at the
moment Ron the whole document will be
available for consultation but we will
speak to the specific um items that are
significant for this financial strategy
and those are summarized in the report
on
[Music]
page yeah page 113 of four books
summarizes the main changes for this
financial stry and all of those will be
familiar to yourselves counselors
because we've been talking about them
across the past
year the focus and the strategy has been
on the challenges so as allerted to an
infrastructure strategy depreciation and
funding of renewals and our and our
Capital program is one of the challenges
as is inflation as is aect of
Revenue
questions
anybody while Tom gets his act together
I'll I'll ask the question he was going
to ask before which was um if we have a
I guess an infrastructure strategy that
doesn't have a straight line but more of
a curve based
on um useful end of life or whatever
Russell said it was um how does that
change out the way we do with
depreciation so the depreciation and and
how we're modeling it is is similar we
actually expect that assets will have an
extended life and we actually factor
that in but the difference with
depreciation is it's the cost to replace
an asset so if we put an pipe in the
ground today and it might cost us
$100 um the time we come to replace it
in maybe 50 60 years we start
depreciating to replace it in 50 60
inflation will expand that so
depreciation needs to keep up with both
inflation and extra life so it's it's
not uncommon for the lives of assets as
we calculate depreciation to keep going
out um if we were to start to get actal
on it we might need a bigger Finance
team um or the ACT becomes much more
complicated than what it probably needs
to be but we do know that depreciation
will need will have some catch UPS along
the way through that through that
revaluation cycle because we have to
effectively at the moment through the
strategy work out how we bring back and
catch up that 215 million increase that
we had in the value of our
infrastructure Network at June 22 when
we did the revaluation because that's
saying now if we had to replace our
networks today the whole lot it would
cost us 2 15 million more than what we
had thought at that time so that's where
we have to um bring that back over time
that's where the strategy is sort of
looking at how we would bring that back
over the period of the 10
years okay any further
questions so I mean this will come back
to the same
point but the you know if if we look
historically and if you look even going
forward um
although we depreciate at let's say x we
actually have only completed engineering
works it's sort of 70 or 80% of X
historically and going forward we're
predicting it's going to be kind of 80
90% of X so we don't actually do work at
the rate of depreciation and and and
despite that you know we don't see bus
pipes all over the
place um and the reason for that is
because you know in my view we'd
appreciate at a faster rate than we need
to that would be my view so if you if
you if you straight line appreciate if
you take an asset which has got a when
you buy it on the name plate it says it
last 20
years that's that's equivalent to the
example I gave before that when a baby's
born it might have an expected life of
76 years but by the time on an act
areial basis the time that baby gets
sent in the middle age in fact on an act
areial basis predicted life is not 76
predicted life is 80 or 85 or 100 or
whatever and it's just use the word
actal it's just statistics statistically
if it if it man if it survives that long
it's going to last beyond its its life
and and you know I would argue the
reason that we managed to get away with
let's use that word not investing at the
rate of depreciation in terms of
Replacements and yet we don't see um bus
pipes all over the place is for that
very reason at the actually last longer
than it says in the name plate if they
if they'd survive the first few years
they last longer than it it says in the
name plate so my my question again um
and I don't I mean it's a difficult
question to answer St off the bat but if
we did take it alone for the fact you
might need 50 accountants to do it but
if you if you did take an Actuarial
approach to um depreciation as a as
an um ages
would
that well logically it should actually
reduce
depreciation and and and and a giant
problem we've got going forward is to
trying to match depreciation which is
Leap up because the the the overall
value assets is lap up and and we're
wearing my VI we're wearing a giant hair
shirt by just straight line and
depreciation for those
assets I don't really expect an answer I
mean it's a kind of challenge to think
about it sure and I can't see the the
other challenge I guess is what will the
audit response be to that change and I'm
not saying we should shy away because of
that we might want to consider that as
well so the the financial strategy
actually deals with that in page 120 of
board books so we do look at the
statistical um deviations about if an
asset says it's to be have a 50-year
life we could be within one or two um
statistical deviations of that so we
could be 15 years early or we could be
15 years later and I'm sure um Russell
was up here with us remember a point of
time a number of years ago where we had
failure of a certain lot of pipes that
were much newer than 50 years and that
so then that balances out where they
were being replaced and they wouldn't
have been fully depreciated they
wouldn't we wouldn't have recovered the
depreciation so it does go both
ways
Michael through yourself um yeah
this is actually um a lot more difficult
than do you fund appreciation or
renewals um because you need to look at
it from a network perspective and I
think Russell in the infrastructure
discussion um highlighted the some of
the nuances we're we're in a first cycle
in relation to infrastructure as a
country so we we don't necessarily have
enough data yet in relation to the
infrastructure um but it's never going
to match in relation to your
depreciation renewals which is a
challenge we have with the Auditors and
the reason it will never match is
because you start depreciating from year
one you don't Rel replace your network
in year one you replace it down the
track and we were're in that first cycle
of of replacement so there was very
little infrastructure replaced in those
first 50 years of ownership of assets
but we were still trying to um put a
portion of rating in there to actually
allow for that you know 50 to 100 years
ago should have been um we're now in a
state we're trying to get back to
funding depreciation that won't match
our renewals our renewals need to match
what the infrastructure strategy
indicating we need to replace our
funding should match what we our long
run depreciation so we're funding and
rating the right people for the right
thing so we're funding the Next
Generation for um the assets we're going
to be replacing not necessarily um
funding the replacement of today's
assets and that's that's the challenge
is getting the balance right between
what you're rating for and what you're
replacing they won't match um so we
should know that we use it as a proxy
because it's a network to check it but
we also know that they won't match but
they should they should be within um K
what we've got the issue is is not only
are when we in the first cycle uh we're
also now the the whole infrastructure
was put in in one generation component
we're now coming through to that whole
infrastructure as a country coming due
all at the same time so the ability to
spend is just not there because there's
not the capacity to do it um that was
the affordable water component the
funding component is slightly separate
but the reality is we can't we can't
actually do the investment in the in the
scale that we need to be doing to
replace
that goes back to the infrastructure
strategy um the funding issues actually
come back to our strategy as a country
probably over the previous 50 years not
the strategies we're currently trying to
do which is we've learned over the years
and we're starting to get our strategies
right going forward I think we've still
got a lot of lessons to learn going
forward as a council we've made we made
a call in relation to the replacement um
and depreciation and and in the last
cycle we're now the catch up to the
strategy and indicating in the strategy
is trying to get back to fund the right
people for the right assets try and fund
the future rate payers for the
replacement of those assets going
forward we're not quite at that cycle
yet um it is very complicated and um
it's because you got a massive Network
and and I think of it from a country
perspective we've got a this problem is
not unique to enago it's every Council
that's got the same
problem some much worse than
us any other
questions somebody like to move the two
recommendations gr I haven't got a
question I've actually got a solution
excellent the country we need an ACC for
infrastructure if you think about the
model that works in ACC and how it
funds we actually need that for
infrastructure so there you go take that
to National so just out of curiosity I
have when you think about
it be it's it's not a flippant disc done
that 30 40 years ago would be I have
suggested again to the incoming
government that you know hate
centralization that one of the things
they could centralize into into a
Ministry of infrastructure would be
three
Waters roading which we don't have the
right formula for at the moment
Emergency Management South Emergency
Management
and
Telecommunications for emergencies those
four could be and should be funded by
taxes which means our taxes would go up
but our rates would drop
accordingly and there is
some desire to be looking at that
because two of those areas three Waters
and roading are in serious need of help
and can't be done through
rids any other questions no would
somebody like to move those two
recommendations
jeez you complely down Alex and
Lesley all those in
favor carried um and the last one is the
issue of f it up the levels of services
kpis and Target again
um
Rihanna so again um May I'll take this
report as read um you have seen through
all of the presentations from the
activity and asset managers their
proposed performance targets um there is
quite a structured legal framework that
these all need to fit within um in terms
of the Local Government Act and the
accounting standards that we need to
comply with as well um I'll just draw
your attention to one proposed change in
the way that we group the activities
that's for the purposes of reporting and
easing communication with the public the
general Services activity which covers
all our non-core services
um is quite large so therefore proposing
splitting it for this long-term plan
into two groups um those two proposed
groups are the leisure Recreation and
well-being Services Group and the
corporate and Regulatory Services Group
um it doesn't have any impact on the way
Council delivers it its activities it
just talks about how it just impacts
rather how we talk about those
activities um so I'm happy to take any
questions y so i' I've got one for your
um we get regular reports about kpis and
service level targets that generally
show that we achieve about 74% when you
look at the cluster we regularly seem to
be about a quarter under now I know
there's probably reasons for each one
but one of the things that raises with
me is are we setting aspirational
targets that we actually don't achieve
or are are we sitting underneath
regulatory targets which we have to
comply with I'm not asking you to to
respond to that today but just give some
thought to that going forward yes so um
it's it's both essentially there are
some Dia set targets that we cannot
change um and just one missed event in
regulatory or in some of the storm order
services for example means that whole
level of service is missed um and and
there's nothing that we can do about
that as a council um alternatively in
some areas um we are suggesting a
revision of some targets to um bring
them into a more realistic range so for
example the Democratic process
satisfaction Target um we knew that when
we went to an online survey we were
going to see some changes as a result of
methodology we're also seeing National
Trends in terms of reduced satisfaction
right across the country with how people
are feeling in terms of their
opportunities to engage with the
Democratic process therefore still a
stretched Target But A reduced Target is
suggested um but you'll see there are
targets there for each kpi um and all of
those are are in most cases either
maintained or increasing so that we've
got that step pathway towards
Improvement yeah I just wonder sometimes
about the the staff impact of having a
an aspirational Target that in some ways
is not achievable so problems say we
want 100% of something and we get 98%
you should be patting somebody on the
back for that um but we tend to it's a
negative result so any work that happens
in that area would be great I think Ria
um thank you pretty much similar to your
question Mr me so that's been I this is
really good because it's given me an
opportunity to go through and actually
understand a lot more areas than than I
had before I looked at at the draft
levels of service and the kpis the
question I have is it's a minor one but
if you could help with an answer be
great on page3 of boardworks under the
regulatory Services I'm looking along
the level service the measures a
Baseline and then the trend and what I'm
seeing in this is there seems to be
trend of where a lot of the measures are
not
applicable so when I look at those areas
housing um Regulatory and over those
measures have we got
no no prior Trend that could fit inside
there that we have from actual
historical
data um or is it has it changed that
significant we we can't put a measurable
Trend in there instead of not
applicable so through you chair
um those ones are ones that are set by
the DIA right and they are required to
be
100% um so the trend is really the trend
column is really just to give you at a
glance is this something that we're
trying to increase to maintain or in the
case of for example waste of landfill
there's actually there are some ones
we're trying to decrease um so the trend
line is for information we could change
not applicable to
maintained that would mean the same that
doesn't tell me anything it says that
one we're not that gives me more of a
negative um glance over it that we're
not achieving something when it's got
not applicable because that's where's
the measure the measure's there but it's
it's simply another way of communicating
the information it's about the trend
line there are targets for every year
though MH yep
thank
you sorry I just di it off there yep any
other questions oh Grant sorry yeah just
page 145 of B books the Queens Park cre
of the national garden garden of
national significance does that
preclude the use of Queen Park in any
form in terms of functionality like by
driving for a really high Benchmark like
that that's that prevent sort of it
being used as we've heard from active
sou earlier in the hearing you know just
with people just using it in a normal
way will it mean there's areas you know
taken out that are just for view as
opposed but could be used for
activity I can't answer the specifics
around what it goes into that award for
um National C but I'm certainly not
aware of any limitations of use but we
could come back with further information
from the parks team on that yeah I
suppose you know we've got to find a
balance we don't want it to be a
beautiful Park that no one can
functionally use and get benefit out of
as a community and we've just heard from
active South and how valuable they see
it as part of a city jaw so it's Bing
the balance I think it's important to
try I guess the other issue is to what
amount of resources do we portion to
keep that standard up which could be
used elsewhere yeah that's
right thank you any other questions EVN
um can I just through you Mr um
work to ran and Patricia the
satisfaction surveys have we got a way
of filtering out
people who adversely affect statistics
say the quality of bus transport when
they never ever use bus transport but
they but
they reflect negatively on it you know
some of the some of the systems that you
use um for satisfaction surveys give you
a tree which takes you in a direction
depending on whether you answer yes or
no it's the same with the buses uh with
the library or the polls can is there a
way of filtering out the people who are
negative for the sake of being negative
as opposed to those who actively use a
service so Rihanna before you answer
that um it raises a really interesting
point around do you survey the community
about whether the library is good or do
you survey the people that use the
library yeah um
and the former we do it at risk because
some people just don't agree with
libraries and don't agree with buses
either um and so that gives us ends up
giving us poor results or poor results
and we might get if we just canvas the
people that use the facilities so um
correct the way that we survey at the
moment is for all the kpis we are
surveying users of those services so um
when we survey the residents there is a
skip logic within the system that the
researchers use and if you don't use the
buses then you are not asked the
questions about what your satisfaction
is we do frequently use the resident
survey to get information from people
who are not users um we vary questions
on a quarterly basis so for example
we've asked people who don't use the
library why don't you use the library is
there a reason and that's helped inform
Library decision making so it is a
really good tool to reach right across
the um the network and people who use
and don't use services and that
flexibility that we have every quarter
does give us an ability but we you can
be assured that the satisfaction results
are from those who use the services
thank
you I think that's helpful because I
mean we had an example a couple days ago
when we did
the lower E Street uh submissions that
came in one of the people that came in
to submit um admitted to me that they
haden't been to the mall
haven't been into est3 since we've
upgraded and so that sort of made a
little bit hard for me to understand
what they were what they were asking for
without knowing what we' already
provided like a little bit you're taking
away walkner but I actually haven't seen
what You' you've got in as a
replacement great yeah I'll move you'll
move excellent second re any further
discussions there being none all those
in favor carried somebody like to move
us to go out of no need to
done oh no oh we're at the end of the
meeting I just need a beard for tonight
cuz I've got to go home and tell my
other half that it was option
one exactly have you been
offed yeah probably I'm sure you it's
called a dog house I
think yeah yeah she'll be listening to
this live
unfortunately just before we go off just
like to thank those that on uh have been
on live stream and we're about to
disappear